Alice pas ce soir ok j'lève mon verre
pour mon ami pr tu vois c'est mon
travail d'historien et rien d'autre bien
s hisorien que la France nous a donné
c'est maman qui m'a demandé de tappout
là jeis au restaurant va
mourir ma grand-mère je la connaissais
même pas
en excusez-moi monsieur vous nêtes pas
ça fait combien de temps que tu n'es pas
revenu au pays presque 30
ans tuonis pas c'esti tu sais qu'on va
suser parce que
car
vousesra pour tradition d'ueillir les
noirs avec
ferve nous attend Mons procéder à des
examens plus approfondis à Paris
n'importe quoi excusez-moi vous avez le
Wii ici
internet faudrait mieux voir un Ker
quelqu'un boit quoi fr quand même un
sorcier attends tu V me faire voir qu'il
y a encore des gens qui font
ça France croass liignant tu m'as fait
vibrer mais ça va pas non mer commencer
tout à m'emmerder Alice on y va Alice
mar que tu me C dessus arrête ça papa
pourquo tu pas
déguis
tuler carnaval jours par pour viv ça
veut dire quoi pour
don
est-ce que vous pourriez parler un peu
moins fort s'il vous
plaît il est
blanc